yo what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and i have another
hardware review video for you guys this
one being of the ifrogs air pollution
d33 uh noise isolating earbuds uh so
like you heard there this is from ifrog
so you can check them out at the link in
the description i'll have a link to
their website as well as a link to this
exact product because there are actually
two versions of the d33 earbuds uh so
this is a full size version of the d33
earbuds they come here in a nice
carrying case that actually says eye
frogs if you can see that on the zipper
which is a nice touch i do like
headphones that come with a carrying
case
but here are the earbuds themselves um
so yes these are not only noise
isolating earbuds um you can see they
are full size uh they come with three
different sized um
three different size uh plugs that go
into your ears so this is the medium
sized ones you can have the larger or
smaller sized ones
so i love the medium-sized ones on just
because they fit my ear pretty well
and the sound was very very nice now you
may or may not be able to tell here that
the right side of this earbud is a lot
longer than the left hand side
this is because the right hand side goes
around your neck if you've ever used
these types of earbuds before the right
side goes around your neck and it's kind
of like that uh it's very convenient
though i actually like uh earbuds that
do that and the sony earbuds that i was
using before uh use the same style
i'm not sure what that style is called
but there you go
on the front here we see this is a 3.5
millimeter headphone jack which will
work with your cell phone uh if it does
have a 3.5 it'll work with any pretty
much any ipod model it'll work with the
iphone 3g but not the original iphone
i was able to use an adapter for my cell
phone which actually has a 2.5
millimeter headphone jack and that
actually did work quite well and the
sound there was no degrading in the
sound of any kind
um
the what i liked about these earbuds
were that uh
basically uh the nine millimeter driver
size provides a really really clear uh a
really really clear sound and if you can
see uh the shape of these earbuds it's
just a little bit uh slanted in this
side here you can see it's black and uh
yellow on the back side so it's very
very nice angles and very nice
looks the way they design these earbuds
so they're very well made
i like the crisp the crisp noises the
sounds that you hear with these earbuds
on is pretty much unparalleled for uh
the the price of these earbuds um they
are available for 19.95 at the ifrog's
website
uh which again is in the description uh
but the only con that i really had with
these earbuds was that the base was not
the strongest
of any earbuds now these again granted
are not 200 noise canceling over-the-ear
headphones but they did lack a little
bit of bass um but i did like that the
the sound that i actually heard out of
these at these drivers and out of these
earbuds was very very clear and if you
can see if i take the earbud off here
it's a fairly it's a decent sized driver
you know it's it's they're just a 1995
earbuds and they're very very well made
uh for the price that you get so i say
if you're if you're looking for a pair
of earbuds that are 19.95 that are 20 or
less you definitely want to get uh
you're going to want to take a look at
these earbuds they are very very nice
and they've gotten lots of great reviews
um they are comfortable and they do like
they say in the title they are noise
isolating so if you do go ahead and plug
these up you're not going to need extra
power or anything these are noise
isolating earbuds
so that's basically the gist of these
products i say they are worth every cent
and i'm going to give these an 8.5 out
of 10.
for the crispness of the noise the nice
design the colors which you can
definitely change on their website you
can customize which colors you do like
uh to suit your needs or your wants you
can definitely uh change the colors of
these but overall eight and a half out
of ten very nice earbuds and if you're
looking for a
pair of budget earbuds you're going to
want to look into these so again this
has been marcus brownlee here from mkbhd
if you like what you saw here just go
ahead and subscribe that button should
be up there if i'm not a partner yet
anyway thanks for watching this ifrogz
video review and go ahead and check out
the link in the description and
subscribe peace